we're ready to go thanks for joining us
on a wednesday night
hits it on the ground on the 2-0 pitch
altuve bobble stays with it and is able
to throw out tavares
this ball hit to center field hit pretty
well springer on the move still on the
move checking out the wall and george
eases up to put it away
springer knew he had to get on the move
in our hurry and wanted to make sure he
knew where that wall was for the second
out
and he pops this one up playable a led
miss diaz
in foul territory and he puts it away a
seven pitch first inning i should have
said that
so here's altuve and he pops this one up
his shallow right field and tavares
takes control of it like a good
centerfielder will
one away one out and one on for michael
brantley batting 299
and brantley hits it in the air to right
deep it sends back gallo
at the wall looking up see you later
back-to-back games with a home run for
michael bradley this one's a two-run
shot and it's two to nothing astros
puts this one on the ground second base
backhand pick and a good
strong throw over to first 117 career
home runs 113 singles and he goes down
swinging here
as javier picks up his first strikeout
of the night it might be a pretty good
pitch to try to finish him off
and he does get correa to swing and miss
there's the first strike out of the
night for alley everybody
is saying that and has said that about
tom seaver
swinging a miss three-pitch strikeout
anderson tejada
or tajed excuse me goes down swinging
christian javier picks up his second
strikeout and makes quick work
spring training of last years he was
dealing with some health issues this is
pop
towards the cap towards the top of the
roof and that ball
is going to be caught it hit
the roof is that going to be called a
fair ball or a foul ball
i think that's what chris woodward's
coming out of the dugout saying the
girder it hit might have been in foul
territory but the umpires are going to
talk about it
jeff mathis still has a bat in his hand
but i'm not sure if he's
they're going to review this yeah now
that's the thing the call is on the
field is out
correct i didn't know you could review
this
what are they going to be reviewing foul
fair or foul or are you reviewing if it
hit
[Music]
out all right wow call will stand
dizzy a line drive out the deep right
center his first time up
kenner falefa turns on one deep out to
left it's gone
a home run for kinder philippa and it
wouldn't be a game in houston if he
didn't hit one
it's two to one what'd you call him the
minute maid masher
was that the nickname that we've given
outstanding work on this kid's day this
ball's hit hard towards tucker and he'll
leap
and make the catch kyle tucker in right
field robs derek dietrich
that's out number one appreciation from
his picture yeah getting some love from
christian javier
disciplined wow by the front office the
next day and he knew going home that
that was going to happen
maldonado strikes out swinging went away
zolac
grounds it out and hits this one sharply
past javier but altuve's there now tube
with a strong throw to get
nick so lacking and even though he's
cruising along with
a 10-pitch inning and a seven-pitch
inning with joey gallo do up
dusty baker coming out of the dugout he
wants to go lefty on lefty with gallow
in this two-one
game and dusty's gonna let him stay
got him christian javier strikes out
joey gallo for out number two
that is his first strikeout since the
third inning and his third strikeout of
the game remember always being
shocked that that was him
it's a swing and a miss correa chases
strike three
and a little throw down to first will
complete another one two three for
allard
but swung at every pitch he saw that
game and he foul tips one here caught by
maldonado and he goes down on strike
sonoli paradis
picks up a strikeout right out of the
gate two double plays turned yesterday
in the left field brantley is going to
get there and put it away for out number
two
runner on the go maldonado with a pitch
to throw and he is
out by a mile machete guns him down
altuve with a tag
but at the same time he can rare back
and give you 95.
just a little tapper ryan's gonna have
to make the play himself he
does to yuli in time for the first out
connor falefer retired one away in the
ninth
there you go swing and a miss strike
three chu goes down
swinging for the second out pressly
picks up his first strikeout
two out of no one on for nick solac
swing and a miss maldonado is gonna have
to make the throw
it is in time and the astros win
two to one martin maldonado
makes the throw all the way on the line
to first base
to nail nick solak to end this game
plummer that was a much needed victory
for the astros